okay these are very serious and
concerning allegations you asked me as a
parent I would be extremely concerned
about that I mean I think in In fairness
I don't know precisely what was said at
what time but certainly you would expect
allegations of that nature to be dealt
with very robustly and very promptly and
I think what we're now seeing today is I
understand there's going to be a meeting
with the police and that's absolutely
right and it may be K that in the
fullness of time there will need to be
investigation about how this allegation
was handled that's that's quite possible
but right now I think it's important in
the interest of that victim of that
complainant that this is dealt with as
quickly and fairly and as robustly as
possible so you know let's let's look in
the fullness of time about what's
happened thus far but I think it's
important to give them the space to get
to the bottom of what happened because
these are very serious and very
concerning sure are the presenter was
only uh suspended this weekend after the
sun broke the story not when the
complaint was first made in May of this
year are you content that the BBC took
the family's complaints seriously you
know well the only difficulties I don't
know precisely what was said I've looked
at the Timeline the suggestion that
something was said in May and then
something said subsequent I don't know
that I mean it may I don't know
precisely what was said what I do know
is that if these allegations were in
substance made then one would have
expected very prompt action to be taken
as I said I don't know precisely what
was said and I do think that in the
fullness of time this will need to be
considered in the round but right now
these are you know very serious
allegations and potentially the you know
the police are involved and we'll have
to see what takes place but I want them
to get on with it that's the key Point
yeah I think it's more it's even more
important to press this May issue
because the mother
says that payments to her child the
alleged victim carried on after May
because the BBC did nothing about it
yeah this child the mother says has a
drug addiction a crack cocaine habit
payments were made and the child was in
a position where they could buy more
drugs as a result this could have ended
much much worse couldn't it well it
absolutely I suppose the only the only
hesitation in my voice is not that I
don't think that's incredibly seriously
I serious I do it's simply that as I
understand it there's a slight dispute
as to what the the BBC saying what this
individuals I simply don't know another
payment absolutely okay I completely
agree and the mother says there's no
reason to dodge her at the moment or
ever she says there was another payment
after she contacted BBC to say my my
son's my child's life is in danger and
if that's right it's a boy or a girl
okay life is in danger yeah please
please speak to your presenter if that's
right then it's astonishing then it's
astonishing and uh you would have
expected robust action to be taken much
more quickly as I said the only thing
that I don't know precisely what was in
that's why there needs to be a full
discussion of this in the fullness of
time but if what you're saying is
correct then your point is is very sound
one and you would have expected
extremely prompt action because these
allegations are extremely serious so I
you know I'm with you on that okay
um this is a public figure who works for
a broadcaster paid for by the public is
it in the public interest to know who
the presenter is this is quite a
difficult I know Nuance legal issues so
no well no that's right I mean I'm
actually I'm not going to criticize him
at this stage because it will depend on
all sorts of things so for example if an
allegation were made against you then
and it was of an extremely serious
nature then I don't think it would
necessarily be appropriate to name you
immediately until they've been a full
investigation and that's why if I may
say so it's really important the time is
of the essence because there is a public
interest in this I accept equally there
is a public interest in ensuring that
people aren't defamed as well so it's a
matter of fact and degree not every
single immediate allegation would need
to be lead to that person being unmarsh
so to speak but there does need to be
the process that is continued so that
there is sufficient detail in that
investigation to potentially justify
that important step because you know
once once this once the allegation is
publicly made and that individual is
unmasked the consequences can be very
serious to say nothing at the potential
legal knock-on information but what
about the other presenters who are being
defamed as a result
wow that that is why time is of the
essence that is precisely why times of
the essence and if your earlier point is
correct about the fact that an
allegation was made back in May and that
it was in effect sat on that's why that
is particularly serious because this has
knock-on implications not just for the
people at the center of it and let's
remember of course first and foremost
the complaint the victim in this case
but also for others who get uh caught up
in it but I'm not at this stage without
knowing all the facts and that's why in
the fullness of time we'll want to see
the chronology
if he was sat here today what would you
ask well what I would ask him at the
moment is what are you doing today to
make progress on this and what are you
going to do to ensure that you give
every possible support to the police and
to any subsequent inquiry if that's what
should take place so I want to focus on
what's going to happen now in terms of
support what I also would want by
whatever commitment is to complete
transparency about how this was handled
in the fullness of time and and that I
think is important but act one scene one
if you like is to ensure that what
happens today is as prompt and as full
and open and transparent as possible
um what do you think of the director
General is he doing a good job
generally
look I think it's one extremely
challenging job I'm not here to come and
beat up the BBC which I think is a very
important public service broadcaster
that doesn't which which and I'm sure
exactly it does extremely important work
I've just been to the G7 in Japan and I
can tell you you know the the BBC is
part of our soft power internationally
and it has got a reputation so so but
the thing about the BBC is it does stand
apart it does have a reputation it is
part of our soft power overseas but that
is undermined if it doesn't address
these issues very promptly and fully and
consistent with the standards that the
British people would expect and that's
why you know this is a serious matter
most first and foremost for the
complainant and indeed for the person at
the center of it but also for the BBC
and as somebody who wants to see this
BBC do well I want them to respond to
this well and professionally okay talk
to me
um about rape prosecutions which you
want to talk to us about
um today
um I understand what you're saying about
you know you you're going to make sure
that more people are potentially
Prosecuting but this success rate is
still very low well can I just set a bit
of context so two years ago we set a
very ambitious and stretching Target to
recover the criminal justice system so
far as rape is concerned and compared to
the last quarter pre-covered so strip
out the whole impact of covid the number
of cases referred by the police to the
CPS for charging decision is up by 130
the number of charges done made by the
CPS is up by 90 percent and the number
of cases received into the Crown Court
is up by 160 so very significant upper
trajectory now it's the job is not done
by any means and will come on to some
further statistics but it's worth
reflecting that the number of people
being prosecuted for it is now higher
than in 2010 and I think from a low bar
no what higher than in 2010 so I mean
that wasn't a particularly low bar but
of course we want to go higher so that's
why we're rolling out this National
operating model for operation siteria
which is how the police and the CPS work
together far more in a formal kind of
Collegiate and collaborative way also by
2024 which is not a million away we're
gonna have an additional 2 000 specially
trained rape investigators and also
every police officer being recruited
into the police will have specific
training in this so you know I'm not
suggesting job done far from it
about the trajectory is really really
improving I want one final thing those
who are convicted are getting sentenced
to on average are 30 percent longer in
jail than in 2010. so you know important
progress job not completed by any means
but um I think in the interest of
balance if you want to get the message
out that people are being convicted
punished and disgraced for this
appalling crime okay it's good to talk
to you this morning Justice secretary
thanks for joining us thank you very
much appreciated thank you